an attempt by china to secure a sweeping
security and trade deal with 10 south
pacific islands remains elusive chinese
foreign minister wang yi has was hoping
to sign such a pact during a stop in
fiji part of his diplomatic tour of the
region but juan came away from a virtual
meeting with his south pacific
counterparts without a deal he urged
them not to be too anxious about his
country's aims in the region and
promised to clear the air
after the meeting china will release its
own position paper on our own positions
propositions and cooperation proposals
with pacific island countries
and going forward we will continue to
have ongoing and in-depth discussions
and consultations to shape more
consensus on cooperation
but the leader to that commitment saw
charm offensive to get the pacific
nations on board one that set alarm
bells ringing in canberra but also as
you will see in our next report in some
pacific islands as well
a whistle-stop charm offensive by
china's foreign minister wang yi
he's spending 10 days island hopping in
the pacific
seeking to deepen beijing's regional
clout
at the centre of the tour a proposed
cooperation packed with 10 pacific
island nations
china is calling it a common development
vision
but a draft of the plan shows its
ambitions go much further
beijing will become more involved in
regional security
training police officers and expanding
its cyber
reach
it would also gain greater access to
natural resources and sensitive marine
mapping in return beijing's dangling the
carrot of a free trade deal along with
access to china's lucrative market
it's also offering financial assistance
including humanitarian and pandemic
relief
the deal would drastically increase
china's role in the politics security
and economy of the south pacific
that has countries like australia and
the us rattled
because of their geographical proximity
and long-standing strategic interests in
the region
the u.s state department has expressed
alarm saying beijing might use the
proposed accord to exploit the islands
and fuel regional tensions
concerns echoed by australia
ahead of monday's meeting micronesia's
president david panwello penned an
eight-page letter warning fellow pacific
island leaders that the agreement
threatens to bring a new cold war era at
best and a world war at worst
china's brushing off those fears
to the pacific island countries china is
not a newcomer but an old friend with a
long-standing friendship the rapid
progress in the relationship between
china and the pacific island countries
does not come out of thin air but has
naturally progressed over time
china's adamant that the deal has no
political strings attached
but with not all pacific island leaders
convinced it has more diplomatic blitzes
ahead to calm their fears
and joining me now for more is rory
metcalf he is head of the national
security college at the australian
national university in canberra rory
china hasn't been able to sign off on
its security and economic deal with the
10 pacific island states as it wanted to
why do you think that is
well this is a significant moment in
china's attempt to dominate the pacific
and i think china has overreached so i
think we've seen a
convergence of several factors in the
past few days the um the overreach the
the hubris if you like of
uh china and and foreign minister uh
wang yi the attempt to uh to to wrap
many countries into a mini-dimensional
agreement security
economics culture development fisheries
etc
and of course there was going to be
opposition so i think what's happening
now is that there's a divisiveness that
china is bringing to the region and the
cracks the divisions are beginning to
show
because the small island countries
cannot reach consensus on doing a deal
with china therefore the deal has been
put on the shelf but the other piece of
the puzzle i think is the way that the
new australian government has been
showing real leadership and real
engagement with the pacific island
countries not telling them to
refuse or ignore china but to remind
them that the choices that they are
making about their development are for
the long term and that they had better
read the fine print of any deal and in
addition the new australian government a
labour government has a much more
progressive foreign policy than the last
one and therefore is telling pacific
pacific island countries what they need
to hear from australia on climate change
which is obviously an existential issue
for them so it is an important way
i'd like to get back to the uh the the
pacific island states and uh there does
appear to be somewhat an appetite for
cooperation with beijing doesn't they i
mean you're talking we have the smaller
arrangement a security arrangement with
the solomon islands a bilateral
agreement with samoa so there is some
sort of an appetite isn't there for
cooperation with beijing
oh look no question i mean these are
countries with enormous development
needs it's understandable that any
country
offering
the loans or the infrastructure or the
technology to help them fill that gap is
going to receive an audience and so
china is part of the solution for the
pacific but it's not the whole solution
and so what we're also seeing
is uh division come to the surface
within countries like solomon islands
for example where uh part of the
community wants closer ties to taiwan
part wants closer ties to beijing part
is worried about the impact of chinese
power and many in that community still
want australia engaged so he's going to
be a a really
multi-coloured tapestry if you like of
foreign assistance to the pacific the
main concern i think from an australian
perspective is that no one country
dominates and it does not use
development as an excuse for a strategic
footprint for security dominance
uh former australian prime minister
scott morrison had referred to the
pacific islands as australia's backyard
did australia drop the ball with
engagement in the region
well
to be fair on the previous government it
was trying to do more uh it had a policy
called the pacific step up where it was
increasing development assistance it was
increasing security assistance and so
forth but the political messaging was
not effective it was not working there
was too much a sense that australia was
either being a little bit condescending
towards small island countries or that
australia was looking at all of their
problems through the prism of u.s china
strategic competition so in fact there's
more continuity than people realize that
the new government i think has got the
tone right
and has for example
made it very clear that we will not use
the word backyard in describing the
pacific instead the pacific is our
neighborhood our region and indeed our
family so talk to us a bit about what
one can expect from this
new government in terms of its
engagement with the pacific island
states
well more broadly pacific uh the broader
indo-pacific asia the new australian
government really has hit the ground
running
we've had a big increase in australia's
national in national security capability
and outlook over the past five years or
so so the new government inherits uh
quite a healthy national security effort
in australia but it will now be much
more engaged diplomatic much more
emphasis on listening on multilateralism
on
broadening the range of countries we're
building ties with not only in the
pacific but also
southeast asia the previous government
rightly elevated the quad of india japan
and the united states as a priority in
australian foreign policy and we will
keep that but the new government will
tie that to the needs of the pacific and
south east asia and we're already seeing
i think some early fruit from that out
of the quad meeting in tokyo last week
where our foreign minister penny wong
implemented a massive increase in aid
spending and helped to encourage greater
quad investment in this region
we leave it there for the time being
thank you so much for joining us today
rory metcalf from the australian
national university thank you so much
thank you